if you want to become a different person
and change your environment because the
environment you have is reinforcing the
person you used to be there's a quote
Chris Williamson said people root for
you on your way up because you remind
them of their dreams and they try to
tear you down once you're there because
you remind them that they gave up on
them I have lived that but then what
happens is people who are not from your
hometown start recognizing for who you
are now there's a say that Jesus wasn't
the Messiah in his hometown you'd think
that the place that someone was from is
the place that would root for it is the
last place that accepted him as Lord in
the story I think there's a lot of Truth
to that it's also why I'm a big advocate
of leaving